bonjour bonjour et bienvenue sur cette
nouvelle émission diagonale TV spéciale
Championnat du Monde Anand Carsen et
bien on va voir aujourd'hui la 5e partie
de ce championnat qui est vraiment
passionnant après l'égalisation d'Anand
donc les deux joueurs sont à une
victoire partout et de nuls et ici donc
Anand a de nouveau les blancs dans cette
5e partie on va voir ce que et bien
Carsen a préparé suite à sa défaite la
dernière fois euh est-ce qu'il va
rejouer les mêmes coups alors on va voir
ça tout de suite alors anande démarre
toujours avec des qu voilà donc il ne
varie pas hein voyez comme Anand essaie
de poursuivre le le plan des champions
du monde j'ai envie de dire hein c'est
ça l'air celui qui a suivi euh euh et
bien
euh des champions comme kpov Kasparov ou
Kramnik c'est-à-dire jouer pendant le
match toujours les mêmes ouvertures euh
jusqu'à essayer de faire craquer
l'adversaire c'est-à-dire essayer de
voir ce que l'adversaire peut jouer et
affiner sa préparation il y a déjà une
préparation avant bien sûr mais
l'affiner au fur et à mesure de façon à
ce que l'adversaire tombe dans des
éventuelles préparations
maison donc on continue cavali F6 jusque
là c'est normal alors là Carsen a choisi
après C4 de Anand qui varie pas dans la
première il avait joué G6 avec une on l'
vu une Grunfeld ou
unand avait tenté un fou de bon très
bien et ensuite il a joué E6 alors
qu'est-ce qu'il va nous jouer là
maintenant dans cette dans cette partie
E6 il revient E6 malgré le fait qu'il
est perdu la partie précédente cavalier
F3 jquici ah et voilà tout de suite là
Carsen varie puisque la partie
précédente il avait proposé un gambiam
c'est-à-dire qu'au lieu de jouer B6 ici
il nous proposait D5 hein si vous
vérifiez la partie vous verrez D5 et on
a eu droit à un
gambidame donc là c'est autre chose
puisque B6 on est on va le voir après
les coups G3 qui est normal pour les
blancs on veut mettre un fou sur G2 et
puis bon ben là il peut y avoir un
danger pour les Noirs bon bien sûr on va
aussi mettre son fond en B7 mais après
le coup suivant des Noirs qui est pas le
seul bien sûr possible il y en a plein
d'autres hein on peut jouer ici on peut
jouer fou7 on peut jouer sans doute fou
a 6 aussi do avoir des variantes avec
fou A6 des choses comme ça pour attaquer
le pion C4 puisque le fou va de l'autre
côté donc pourquoi pas essayer de
l'attaquer donc et il joue fou B4 échec
voilà pose la problème au blanc de
savoir qu'est-ce que je mets en face de
ce fou ça s'appelle la défense euh West
indienne on dit West indienne pour parce
que l'est indienne c'est quand je joue
G6 que je mets le fou à l'est et quand
je sors le fou à l'ouest ici là ici on
appelle ça ouest indienne alors le Fou
est sorti là et puis surtout en fait on
a le le fianqueto ici à l'ouest je pense
que c'est surtout ça en fait c'est ce
fou là qui va venir en B7 donc on a une
défense West indienne de ce fait là mais
on a aussi enfin les deux fous se
développent à à l'ouest quoi voilà donc
on y va avec fou des de alors ça c'est
normal bien sûr j'ppose le fou je suis
très content si les noir échange puisque
je reprends du cavalier ou de la dame et
j'en profite pour développer mes pièces
et les Noirs voilà ne n'échang pas mais
reviennent alors ça ça paraît curieux
parce que pourquoi faire échec pour
revenir en permettant au blanc d'avoir
mis leur fou en D de alors ça l'idée de
derrière ça c'est de dire du côté noir
c'est de de prétendre que finalement le
fou entre des deux est mal placé voilà
donc si effectivement le fou et D2 en D2
est mal placé alors c'est utile de le
forcer à venir en D2 avant de jouerou le
fou en7 bon il est moins bien placé là
que il ne le saait en C1 sinon ces deux
coups n'ont pas n'ont pas de sens donc
cavalier C3 bon très normal de continue
fou B7 on on l'a dit c'est évidemment la
place naturelle du Fou là le fou du côté
ouest ici et on vise sur cette diagonale
ici bien sûr alors bien sûr on peut on
attaque le C F3 bien sûr mais surtout ce
qu'on ce qu'on veut faire c'est protéger
la case E4 voyez hop ici le cavalier
protège 4 hein je peux même mettre d'une
autre couleur cette case
vraiment ici tout à fait tout à fait
importante c'est une case centrale qui
est contrôlée par le cavalier noir et
maintenant par le fou donc ça limite les
possibilités de jouer le coup naturel E4
pour les blancs voilà donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut garder en tête ce cette idée
fou G2 donc là on continue à se
développer normalement hein on verra on
résoudra les problèmes plus tard au
centre et là C6 alors ça c'est un
curieux parce que
C6 va contre l'idée qu'on vient de
donner c'estàd contrôle plus 4 voilà
donc c'est une variante spéciale mais
l'idée pour les Noirs c'est de
surprotéger leur poussée D5 voilà on va
pousser avec D5 et le le pion D5 est
surprotégé par C6 et E6 et en plus bon
j'empêche éventuellement qu'avali de
venir en B5 bon ça c'est pas très pas
très très intéressant mais voilà c'est
surprotéger la case D5 bon pourquoi pas
je un peu curieux mais pourquoi pas
alors là les blancs en profitent bien
sûr Anand se laisse pas impressionner il
joue maintenant 4 puisque le fou ne
contrôle plus donc là E4 est protégé par
le cavalier C3 il n'est attaqué qu'une
fois donc ça suffit pas et maintenant
qu'on a joué C6 bien sûr on surprotège
la case D5 certes mais on a mis euh le
fou un peu de façon inactive hein voil
donc là maintenant D5 des Noirs ça y est
c'est l'heure à la limite c'est presque
une provocation C si on pourrait dire on
invite les blancs à pousser4 et
maintenant on joue D5 ce qui force des
prises de décision au centre voilà donc
alors par exemple pousser E5 pourquoi
pas mais si on joue E5 bon ben on
affaiblit les cases blanches au centre
c'est toujours pareil hein quand on
bouge les pions il y a toujours une
contrepartie
euh et puis le pion D4 risque de devenir
arri parce que ce pion C4 va sans doute
s'échanger par des5 prend C4 où on va
devoir soi-même échanger et on peut on
peut se retrouver en position
éventuellement bon c'est c'est chaud
mais ù le pion D4 pourrait être arriéré
qu' per arriéré c'estd que là
véritablement il serait bloqué donc là
anant joue pion prend voilà bon il prend
directement et voilà il prend du pion e
pas du pion C puision prend puision
prend et maintenant cavalier5 voilà
alors cavalier5 c'est un très très bon
coup puisque le cavalier sur une case
centrale ce qui est toujours mieux et
puis on on empêche les noirs de PR de la
prise en en C4 puisque on a le fou G2
qui attaque B7 voilà donc en mettant le
cavalier là on libère l'action de notre
fou voilà c'est un coup naturel pour
l'instant les noir en une position très
solide aussi petit rock petit rock bon
ça c'est normal ça surprendra personne
et maintenant bien sûr on s'attend à ce
que on sorte la dernière pièce non
développée des noirs éidement c'est le
cavalier c'est ce que fait Carsen
cavalier C6 et on peut dire ici que le
développement est presque terminé il
reste qu'est-ce qu' reste à faire si on
voulait rappeler les les principes
fondamentaux du du développement ici et
bien il reste à trouver une case pour la
dame éventuellement parce qu'on aime pas
la laisser là parce qu'on veut lier les
tours on veut que les tours se protègent
l'une l'autre donc faut trouver une case
pour la dame alors la dame D1 on sait
pas trop où on va la mettre pour
l'instant on pourrait envisager E2 mais
tout de suite il y a une menace en D4
les Noirs ici attaque
le pion D4 donc on n pas le temps mais
si on imaginait que ce pion était
défendu on pour jouer la dame 2 une tour
en D1 l'autre tour en C1 et puis les
noir par contre c'est plus dur pour
trouver une casse pour la dame parce
qu'en C7 elle va se retrouver en
vis-à-vis tour dame donc il faudra la
mettre en C7 tour C8 et ensuite enlever
la dame éventuellement voyez donc les
Noirs c'est un tout petit peu plus
difficile bon c'est normal les noirs
sont toujours un peu plus resserrés dans
l'ouverture ils ont un peu moins
d'espace alors là maintenant décision
d'Anand c'est prendre des5 ça c'est
intéressant je rappel qui a même pu en
D4 mais bon tant qu'on il y a une prise
bon ben il faut que les Noirs réagissent
hein on va pas prendre des4 maintenant
parce qu'il y aurait pu on
prend6 attaque le fou fou prend et pu on
prend F7 échec et ensuite on reprend le
fou ce qui au final nous fait perdre un
pion donc non non il faudrait il faut
envisager de reprendre le pion D5 et ou
alors de jouer cavalier prend le5 comme
le fait Carsen ici on prend le cavalier
d'abord voilà et Carsen sans doute après
bah le forcer hein ah non pas forcé
justement mais si les Blancs avaient
joué on va voir çaprs on va voir ce ça
jou ah non bien sûr si les Blancs
avaient joué prend des 5 c'est possible
ben l'idée des Noirs c'est de reprendre
tranquillement des5 et le fou regardez
c'est vrai que le fou des de est mal
placé puisque la dame contrôle pas des
C voilà donc là ça invite ça peut
inviter après faire des échanges on peut
menacer cavalier prend C3 attaque la
dame il faudrait reprendre échange
généralisé pouf pouf et il y a plus rien
voilà il y a plus rien pour les blancs
donc ça va pas alors que si la dame
contrôlait D5 on pourrait envisager avec
les blancs de prendre prendre prendre et
à la fin il y aurait pion prend et ce
pion serait isolé hein un thème qu'on a
vu dans la dernière partie c'est un pion
isolé c'est une cible sur laquelle on se
on se masse on masse ses pièces et
l'autre l'adversaire est obligé de
défendre donc il est
passif donc c'est pas ce qui a été joué
la anant joue un coup très joli
intermédiaire euh ici hop voilà il nous
joue le coup D6 al je faire tout de
suite D6 voilà très joli attaque le fou
ça veut dire que là attention il y a
deux attaques et même trois parce que le
cavalier est en prise tout est en pris
chez les Noirs mais les blanc ont une
pièce de moins donc évidemment tout ça
est
un petite joutte calculatoire alors
regardons les erreurs qu'il faut éviter
si si les Noirs fais
fou prend
fou bon c'est une pseudo erreur
simplement d'abord on prend le fou7 en
attaquant la dame donc là on a pas le
choix on peut pas on n pas le temps
d'enlever le fou voyez il faut par
exemple faire bah il faut même faire
pion prend 7 parce que sinon c'est puion
on prend tour avec échec puisque je fais
dame et là regardez les blancs peuvent
faire P on prend et on a toujours deux
pièces attaqué et après le naturel ben
je reprends une pièce et bien encore
regardez je prends le cavalier j'attaque
la dame ce qui fait qu'après dame prend
F6 et ben j'ai gagné une pièce dame
prend fou et là j'ai deux pièces contre
une tour hein puisque là cette tour
cette tour ici a son homologue là la
dame a son homologue ici mais c'est deux
fous C deux pièces jouent contre une
tour et deux pièces et bien c'est plus
fort qu'une tour hein bon pas beaucoup
plus fort mais c'est quand même plus
fort voilà alors il vaut mieux encore
avoir deux fous contre une tour c'est
encore plus fort mais fou et cavalier
c'est c'est déjà plus fort qu'une tour
et là on peut faire confiance à Anand
pour pour essayer de transformer cette
cette position même avec un pion de
moins c'est une
partie qui est préférable du côté
blanc donc D6 joli coup intermédiaire
alors c'est c'est difficile de voir
toutes les possibilités mais quand même
on regarde cavalier C6 de Carsen il
revient donc il laisse prendre 7 puis on
prend7 alors là déjà c'est intéressant
regarde un not tout de suite après Dam
prend7 bilan des courses on a ce qu'on
appelle la paire de fou et en face il y
a pas donc c'est déjà un tout petit peu
une petite victoire pour les blancs si
on regarde la position comme ça alors en
compensation de quoi les Noirs quand
même attaquent un pion ici central isolé
on a le fameux pion isolé voilà donc ça
compense he bien sûr c'est pas une paire
de fou gratuite quoi il a qu pion isolé
en face ce pion bah il est tout seul et
puis il va avoir du mal à avancer en
D5 alors donc c'est pour ça qu'and euh
bah va pas garder la paire de fou
longtemps regardez son idée il joue fou
G5 alors fou G5 est toujours très
dangereux puisque là il peut y avoir
simplement cavalier E4 et la prise en F6
avec destruction de la structure du
rock donc il faut faire attention à ça
faut pas laisser traîner le fou là
longtemps parce que on a plus le fou de
case noire donc on peut pas on peut pas
s'en sortir facilement on peut pas
enlever la dame puisque le cavalier
serait pris avec destruction de la
structure et on peut pas bouger le
cavalier puisque dame serait prise donc
il faut il faut quasiment on est forcé
le coup suivant est forcé voilà H6 voilà
alors là euh là c'est un moment crucial
de la partie hein c'est moment crucial
de la partie parce que on peut
envisager pourquoi pas de prendre en F6
c'est faisable bien sûr avec les Blancs
hein puisqu'on est attaqué et après dame
prend F6 jouer un coup comme par exemple
dame à 4 avec l'idée bah on enlève la la
dame de la colonne D puisque on va sans
doute avoir une Tour Noire en face et
les Noirs ne peuvent pas prendre en D4
malgré les apparences bien que la dame
protège parce que le fou G2 ici et bien
sûr a en bavis le fou B7 voilà donc
évidemment cette possibilité cette cette
attaque sur le fou B7 empêche cette la
manœuvre de prise au centre donc on
pourrait envisager ça avec en essayant
avec les blancs de faire pression
justement sur cette diagonale mais ça
risque pas durer longtemps en fait c'est
ça le problème et le pion des qu risque
de tomber donc là n choisit une suite
beaucoup plus punchy et je dirais
presque assez classique dans ce type de
position le fameux pion isolé là on nime
pas le garder longtemps on n'aime pas le
garder longtemps parce que si on peut le
l'éliminer en général c'est une bonne
affaire et c'est ce que font les blancs
D5 voilà D5 ça élimine déjà le pion
isolé parce que Ben après un prise prise
déjà ça serait une erreur pour les Noirs
hein puisque simplement le cavalier C3
viendraend
D5 attaque la dame attaque le cavalier
cavalier peut pas bouger puisque il y a
le fou qui attaquerait la dame et après
ça on prendrait un F6 et c'est un
désastrein cavalier prend F6 fou prend6
et la partie est terminée donc il faut
on peut pas prendre avec les Noirs en
fait voilà donc on est obligé de de
bouger le cavalier voilà cavalier A5 et
là moment crucial moment crucial parce
qu' a plein de possibilités alors c'est
pas facile à évaluer parce que c'est il
y a du calcul à faire mais par exemple
il a cette possibilité là bon on va voir
ce qu'il a joué déjà F prend F6 il a
fait très bien mais il aurait pu jouer
ici un coup qui paraissait très tendu et
très intéressant regardez toujours en
continuant l'attaque c'est le coup
D6 toujours pareil attaque intermédiaire
j'attaque la dame alors bien sûr il y a
une attaque aussi maintenant sur le fou
mais il est protéger d'où l'idée de
cavalier A5 en jouant à5 je protège mon
fou B7 mais la dame est attaquée là et
je peux pas trop enfin si je peux éviter
de de de de perdre le contrôle de la C6
c'est mieux parce que sinon fou prend
encore une fois et le rock est cassé on
voit très vite qu'après dame H5 ça va
être très dur de défendre le
roi donc le dame D8 est forcé
d'accord et là simplement fou prend F6
si prise le rock est est cassé donc dame
prend et là bilan des courses B j'ai un
pion passer avancer alors la question
qu'il faut se poser là c'est est-ce que
ça tient c'est ça le problème parce que
les pions passés avancés c'est bien sauf
que des fois c'est aussi un pion faible
parce que c'est un pion qui est aussi
une cible voilà on voit bien qu'il va
pas pouvoir aller à Dame facilement là
D8 hyper bien protégé donc la question
c'est bien sûr les les ça gêne ça va
gêner les Noirs mais pendant combien de
temps c'est est-ce qu'on va pouvoir avec
les Blancs tenir ce pion en D6 c'est ça
le
problème il faudra analyser ça
longuement c'est impossible de de de
trancher dans comme ça en 5 minutes on
va pas ici voir la préparation d'Anand
mais pourquoi pas pourquoi pas jouer
cette variante ça va l'air intéressant
et la question toute la question qui dit
est-ce que ce pion des C tient est-ce
que vraiment c'est gne les noirs et ou
est-ce que à la fin c'est pas les noirs
qui vont faire
le l'assaut de ce pion le le du pion et
et finir par le gob par l'emporter et
puis là les les blancs rempionn moins en
finale après voilà donc il faut toujours
faut peser ça à long terme aussi il
suffit pas de regarder les coups comme
ça à TR qu coups à long terme si on perd
ce pion malgré que ça il paraît fort
voilà et c'est vrai que bon ben il y a
plus beaucoup beaucoup de pièces pour
essayer de faire des manœuvres d'attaque
et cetera bon mais peut-être peut-être
que c'est jouable voilà difficile à à
dire donc après cavalier A5 D6 était
faisable mais fou pr F6 un choisi plus
simple dam prend F6 et là tout de suite
ça va ressembler à une partie équilibrée
puisqueaprès pion prend E6 et bien alors
évidemment il y a un vis-à-vis mais
c'est pas une vraie menace hein le
cavalier peut reprendre Carsen reprend
avec la dame et alors là bilan des
courses après on va encore jouer
quelques coups tour 1 dame F6 voilà donc
tout ça a étéit forcé hein depuis faut
prend F6 quasiment donc la bilan des
courses ben regardez le problème c'est
qu'on est ici dans une structure de pion
symétrique 33 2 2 donc il y a pas de il
y a pas de de plan a priori déterminé
par une une une asymétrie des pions donc
c'est une position qui paraît un peu
plate mais ceci étant dit les Blancs ont
un petit avantage quand même parce que
bah ils ont déjà placé une tour au
centre et le cavalier est proche de
venir pourquoi pas en D5 ou en E4 pour
attaquer la dame donc venir sur sur une
case centrale et en gros les Blancs ont
plus d'espace et l'initiative maintenant
c'est léger c'est que ils ont même pas
un pion de plus donc c'est quand même
bon a priori tout ça est semble une
bonne affaire pour les Noirs même si ça
paraît euh il y a une petite initiative
pour les blancs est-ce qu'elle est
vraiment suffisante pour en obtenir un
avantage euh plus concret plus solide
euh ça paraît pas être le cas alors on
regarde ce que fait Anand il fait le
joli
cavalier D5 pas
mal cavalier D5 attaque la dame et
propose au noir tu peux changer le
cavalier mais dans ce CASL j'auris un
fou contre un cavalier bon le problème
bien sûr alors fou contre cavalier c'est
bien au final il va mieux avir un fou
cavalier en général surtout quand il a
des pion des deux côtés onarlera tout à
l'heure mais
ici la dame surtout attaque B2 donc on
donne un P en fait et ce que fait Carsen
c'est pas prendre le pion tout de suite
pourquoi d'ailleurs je sais pas parce
qu'en fait il aurait très bien pu le
prendre sans donner son fou B7 et dans
ce caslà il y a même pas on se demande
ce qu'il y a contre le
pion c'est pas
évident il y a pas grandchose parce que
là on peut faire un échec mais après ro
H8 on voit pas trop à quoi ça
sert qu'est-ce qu'il pourrait y avoir
d'autre on pourrait attaquer la
dame B1 mais dans ce cas-là on donne un
deuxième pion c'est chaud alors
peut-être euh peut-être que la dame a
pas de case apriss tour B1 où va la dame
c'est peut-être ça
l'idée B2 et puis on rattaque en B1 et
ou va la dame toujours bon ben elle peut
pas c'est vrai qu'elle peut pas revenir
alors regardez en C3 c'est pris en D4
c'est pris en E5 c'est pris et en F6
c'est pris donc en fait peut-être c'est
ça l'idée de N simplement il force une
nuulle facile bon je sais pas trop c'est
bizarre quand même parce qu'il a les
blancs donc je sais pas donc il a pas
pris Carsen quand même il a fait fou
prend alors là c'est pas pareil parce
que on donne un fou quand même fou prend
des cingles donc là il y a une asymétrie
de pièces il y a un fou contre cavalier
et après euh simplement ici tour à D8 on
a un souci avec ce fou parce qu'il y a
un
clouage donc je peux menacer des coups
comme dame G5 attaque le fou et ben il
s'est foutu parce qu'il est perdu donc
là les blancs faut qu'il trouve une
solution très vite parce que ce fou pour
l'instant il est bloqué alors la
solution classique c'est de jouer ce que
fait an c'est Dame F3 je viens en F3 je
m'enlève la dame de la de du visavis et
je protège le fou voilà et en cas de
dame prend dame il a fou prend dame mais
j'ai laissé le pion B2 en prise et là
cette fois Carsen le prend voilà et là
on se dit bon c'est un peu chaud quand
même parce que j'ai
donné
le pion B2 donc j'ai un pion de moins
oui mais j'ai un pion j'ai un fou au
centre et un fou au centre c'est énorme
surtout quandre un cavalier comme ça
regardez ce cavalier voilà c'est ça
qu'il fallait voir depuis le début les
cases qui
contrôlent sont toutes sous l'emprise du
Fou voilà il peut pas bouger en fait
voilà ça s'appelle un thème de
domination de pièces mineur ici
notamment ici le le fou domine le
cavalier il y a des positions où c'est
l'inverse on a des positions où les
cavaliers dominent les fous ça arrive
aussi c'est un peu plus rare he parce
que cavalier contrôle moins de casass
qu'un fou mais ça arrive aussi voilà et
là ce fou alors non seulement il domine
ce cavalier qui est un peu horgeu du
coup et puis il tape un point
névralgique dans le sens dans le dans le
dans le camp noir c'est le pion F7 où il
y a le roi derrière on a déjà le fou qui
est
dessus plus la dame
d'accord plus plus tard très vite la
tour E7 bon pas tout de suite parce que
par tour 1 est en prise donc va falloir
bouger cette tour mais voyez qu'on on a
quand même en échange du pion un
avantage dynamique voilà alors du coup
les deux avantages se en général se se
compensent c'estàdire que à un moment
donné tôt ou tard les Noirs rendent le
pion pour calmer la la force de
l'adversaire voilà bon alors maintenant
faut voir ce que faitand on a dit que on
aimerait bien jouer t 7 puisqu'on a une
pression déjà mais il faut sortir la
tour à 1 c'est quoi la meilleure cas
sans doute tour à1 c'est ce que fait
Anand parce qu'on je protège le fou et
en plus je crée une petite menace ici
fou prend F7 échec et si tour prend et
bien dans ce cas-là tour prend tour
échec et les blancs gagnent hein donc ça
c'est un faites-vous la main en 2
secondes si c'était au blanc de jouer
fou prend F7 voilà fou prend F7 roi
bouge tour prend tour et c'est terminé
il y a même plus de de clouage du Fou
les les blancs récupérer un pion ils ont
un fou les cases noirs les cases
blanches autour du roi sont faibles là
il y aurait un gros avantage blanc le
cas all est Tor jeu il est pas prêt de
revenir et cetera et cetera donc là
Carsen réfléchit et joue un coup qui
peut sembler un peu
étonnant mais on va voir que c'est
correct dame F6 surprenant puisque là on
met la dame en prise de la Dame Blanche
et là ben an non n réfléchit pas
longtemps dame prend pourquoi parce
qu'après P prend j'ai cassé la structure
la fameuse structure dont on parlait
depuis tout à l'heure là on en a parlé
avec cause du avec le l'histoire du Fou
G5 tout à l'heure le on a cassé la
structure du roi noir alors on a
toujours un fou dominateur puisque le
cavalier peut pas
sortir voyez il peut pas bouger on a un
fou dominateur on a un fou centralisé et
dominateur mais on peut pas en profiter
pour gagner ce cavalier par on a plus le
pion B2 notamment on peut si on pouvait
jouer B4 là on gagnerait une
pièce les Noirs serait obligés de donner
la qualité il serit obligé de donner la
tour tour prend tour prend
euh pour sauver leur cavaliers
all
le et ce fou contrôle aussi la case F7
donc c'est puissant mais on a un pion de
moins bon alors on voit bien que le pion
de moins quand on a des pions comme ça
en face c'est pas très très très grave
et la puissance du Fou donc on a parlé
un peu tout à l'heure c'est de pouvoir
agir des deux côtés à la fois il a un
œil ce fou sur l'elle dame et il a un
œil sur les loit et regard en
contrepartie ce cavalier là ben il joue
pas du tout c'est comme si les blanc
avaient presque une pièce de plus ici
bon alors sauf que évidemment on pourra
pas tenir sur cette case sans s an parce
que les Noirs vont jouer tour 8 ils vont
échanger des tours et puis ça va ça
risque après être difficile donc il faut
faut être
prudent donc là quand même tout recette
voilà l'activité blanche est forte en
échange mais là alors en joueant ça le
problème aussi c'est bien sûr alors là
le Fou est est clouer je peux pas sortir
où je veux parce queil y aurait un
vis-à-vis de tour et tour voilà donc euh
là maintenant jouant ça ma tour D1
disons voilà pour faire plus simple
encore elle est pas protégée
voilà par exemple les Noirs ici
maintenant peuvent envisager de mettre
le cavalier en C4 puisque sur fou prend
tour prend tour
ou en C6 attaquant la tour protégeant à
7 c'est
possible alors Carsen joue d'abord roi
G7 il enlève les possibilités d'échec t
prend à 7 dans tranquille hein il a pas
peur hein pour l'instant alors
évidemment ça fait ça peut faire peur
quand même parce que après tour prend à
euh qu'est-ce qui se passe sur un coup
comme tour D6 qui a l'air très
bien tour D6 c'est très
bien pourquoi ben je protège B6 on sait
jamais puisque maintenant j'ai une tour
qui attaque et j'envisage pourquoi pas
de faire tour D8 et là
clouage simplement ça marche pas parce
qu'on joue simplement fou B3 enfin ça
marche pas si ça fonctionne un peu
c'estàd qu'on est quand même obligé de
faire quelque chose on peut enlever le
fou tout en protégeant la tour classique
hein voilà mais surtout faut pas le
faire un coup plus tard un coup plus
tard c'est trop tard si les noir mettent
une tour là-bas c'est fini il faut le
faire au bon moment vous voyez que c'est
le fou peut quand même sortir puisqu'il
peut protéger sa tour derrière voilà
donc quand on se fait clouer comme ça
c'est un petit truc qu'il faut garder à
l'œil donc roi G7 tour prend à 7
cavalier C6 bon je met le cavalier en
prise mais comme on l'a dit c'est pas
puisque là t prend tour échec donc
maintenant regardez tour B7
tranquillement j'attaque B6 et le
cavalier C6 est attaquer donc on
comprend bien que ce pion va sauter et
là les Noirs jouent le seul coup
cavalier B4 je contre-attaque sur le fou
B5 c'est qu' en cas de prise du pion le
Fou est perdu donc il faut faire la
manœuvre qu'on vient de voir fou B3 est
forcé ou fou F3 hein fou F3 était
possible aussi mais en B3 c'est un tout
petit peu mieux puisqu'on garde un œil
sur F7 hein donc voilà mais après tour
prend tour c'est pareil fou prend et
maintenant ben Carsen peut prendre le
pion A2 et après tour prend B6 bilan des
courses
ici tout petit avantage blanc du fait
que la structure blanche ici est
meilleure que la structure noire là
mais le fou on peut plus dire maintenant
que le Fou est supérieur au cavalier en
finale parce que les pions justement
sont tous du même côté alors comme les
pions sont tous du même côté les deux
pièces mineures n'ont pas vraiment
d'avantage l'une sur l'autre voilà le
cavalier même presque mieux puisque lui
il peut jouer soit les soit sur les
cases noires soit sur les cases blanches
alors que le Fou est limité au cases
blanch mais le fou reste une pièce de
longue portée je peux la mettre là ou là
pour contrôler des cases intéressantes
en attaque mais il a plus d'intérêt à
tappper des deux côtés quoi en quelque
sorte hein de ce côté-là il y a plus
rien à manger quoi voilà donc
l'élimination des pions du nelle
favorise la défense du cavalier
inversement quand on attaque donc avec
un fou on aurait eu intérêt à garder des
pions des deux côtés bon il a fallu
trouver autre chose cavalier C3 alors
pourquoi pour centraliser on veut pas
laisser le cavalier comme ça très loin
de l'action on en profite on attaque le
fou et on va centraliser ce cavalier par
exemple en D5 en E4 voilà al c'est pour
ça que fou F3 est bien regardez toujours
pareil toujours le même thème domination
du cavalier le cavalier n'a pas de case
c'est
terrible bon il a des cases hein bien
sûr il peut aller en A4 il peut aller en
A2 en B1 et les Blancs ont pas les
moyens quand il est pas la band comme ça
de le prendre avec uniquement le fouille
la tour mais on voit bien qu' même qu'il
est dominé qu'il va falloir trouver un
moyen de l'activer autrement
voilà donc là facilement Carsen très
tranquille F5 joli coup tranquille F5
les pions doublés servent à quelque
chose et celui-là il est plus proche du
centre que s'il était là-bas il le met
en F5 donc ben on a la case 4 pour le
cavalier c'est ça l'idée voilà on a
cette fameuse case ici
E4
voilà qui est protégé par le pion F5 et
où le cavalier va pouvoir se recentrer
voilà tranquillement ro G2 tour D8 pas
pressé pour l'instant il il met sa tour
tour C6 attaque le cavalier cavalier E4
et là il y va à N bon il sait que c'est
nul c'est vraiment très difficile enfin
c'est impossible de gagner cette
position fou prend4 pion prend le4 tour
C4 attaque le pion F5 et là joli coup
mais sans sans intérêt en fait G4
évidemment je détruis F5 pour pouvoir
prendre 4 et on se dirige vers la nulle
tour D2 je prends F5 E3 évidemment
j'attaque F2 ici voilà tour4 voyez non
se presse pas tour E4 maintenant
qu'est-ce qui se passe bah si tour prend
échec simplement r G3 tour prend F5 je
prends3 et si pion prend ben ce pion est
perdu hein parce que quand il peut pas
faire dame puceque le roi est là il
suffira de jouer tour F4 tour prend et
puis c'est fini voilà donc après tour
prend F2 roi G3 et t prend F5 les
joueurs conviennent de la nul ici c'est
de jouer mais ça s'arrête là Carsen a dû
proposer nul accepter euh puisque euh
sur tour prend E3 c'est archi nul
évidemment cette position même
d'ailleurs même on a même pas besoin du
pion adverse hein le pion h peut pas
gagner en finale de tour quand le roi
même quand le d'ailleurs même si le roi
est pas devant je crois qu'on doit
pouvoir arriver à annuler le plus
souvent voilà donc une bon une jolie
partie euh qu'est-ce qu'on peut retenir
de de cette partie euh euh bon même si
elle s'est simplifié assez vite il y
avait des moments tendus hein bon euh il
y a eu un
début revenons sur ce début très
rapidement hein donc défense West
indienne donc voilà avec les coups qu'on
a vu avec ce fameux C6 là peut-être
qu'il a surpris Anand ici ce ce C6 là
peut-être pas prévu je sais pas E4 D5
bon puis on prend puis on prend
cavalier5 voilà Anand a cherché des
choses mais bon Carsen a fait aucune
erreur même après le le le coup tendu
des 6 he bon c'est c'est c'est des
coupts que les grands maîtres doivent
connaître ça bien entendu hein
donc cavalier C6 pion on prend dam prend
il y a la paire de fou mais on a vu
qu'on peut pas la tenir longtemps le
pion D4 est potentiellement faible donc
un nanjou une variante simplificatrice
H6 et là D5 très intéressant et voilà et
c'est sans doute là ici ça c'est c'est
le coup normal D5 hein c'est c'est c'est
logique c'est dans ce type de position
et là après c a 5 peut-être D6 voilà
alors peut-être que si Carsen rejoue
cette variante il peut avoir droit à D6
bon ça peut peut y avoir aussi des
variations donc le match continue c'est
tendu une jolie partie bon il y a pas eu
de possibilité de de rentrer dans
quelque chose de de extrêmement tendu
mais il y a eu des petits trucs il
fallait faire attention la moindre
petite faute aurait pu s'avérer être
fatale mais bon une partie un peu
standard quand même voilà sans éclat
particulier donc la prochaine partie
Carsen aura les blancs on va voir ce qui
va se passer alors est-ce qu'on aura
droit à une Sicilienne ou à une défense
de Berlin bah c'est anant qui va avoir
la réponse à moins que Carsen change il
pourrait très bien aussi jouer des4
pourquoi pas donc ben à bientôt pour la
6e partie qui aura lieu B dès demain et
à suivre sur donc sur diagonal TV merci
de m'avoir suivi à bientôt au
revoir